[Musica]
[Applauso]
una qualsivoglia esegesi o glossa la cui
forma comunicativa si giochi di una
foggia volutamente e smisuratamente con
voluta nella forma stilistico espressiva
con ogni probabilità si evincerà seppure
eccellente nell'aspetto estetico dal
punto di vista della pura efficacia
comunicativa un totale e incomprensibile
orrendo casinò o in parole povere per
spiegare bene è meglio parlare facile ma
come mai non lo facciamo sempre
non è che parlare bene o parlare in modo
forbito ricco vada sempre male al
contrario ci sono dei momenti in cui è
assolutamente necessario per esempio
provate a pensare che ne so pare
professionali convention di biologi ok
che devono commentare i risultati di una
ricerca
ovviamente lo faranno usando quello che
si chiama gergo tecnico appunto cioè
delle parole estremamente precise
estremamente specifiche che linguaggio
corrente non può convogliare e quindi va
bene
altro esempio
in caso di sovradosaggio può provocare
cito lisi epatica che può evolvere verso
la necrosi massiva e irreversibile con
conseguente insufficienza epatocellulare
acidosi metabolica e del cefalo patia
cioè se ne prendi tanto muori male
tutti esempi veri oppure
visto il decreto dei ministri in materia
di contenimento e delle direttive
impartite dal dipartimento della
pubblica sicurezza allo scopo di ridurre
al minimo possibile l'afflusso del
pubblico e di limitare le situazioni
suscettibili di esporre l'utenza ed il
personale operante a situazioni di
contagio si dispone con effetto
immediato che l'attività di ricezione
degli uffici di polizia amministrativa
della questura e dei commissariati tutti
sezionali attaccati ivi compreso
l'ufficio passaporti sia limitata alle
sole istanze riguardanti situazioni in
cui il rilascio della licenza o del
passaporto sia motivato dalla
sussistenza di comprovate esigenze
lavorative motivi di salute o altre
situazioni di necessità che
l'interessato dovrà documentare
c'è il covip facciamo il telefono
questo era
grazie
allora come mai non lo facciamo sempre
ok questa cosa del parlare come si
mangia
sicuramente c'è dell'abitudine siamo
abituati a farlo che in certi contesti
si parla così
però secondo me non è solamente quello
c'è dell'altro il primo impatto con la
comunicazione tra virgolette accademica
l'ho avuta il primo anno di università
quando sono andato a studiare e ho
scelto come primo esame geografia perché
sembrava facile tipo impara le regioni
non era così era molto più difficile e
ho passato settimane a tradurre
capoverso per capoverso dall'italiano al
italiano il libro che dovevo studiare
per l'esame
ovviamente mi hanno bocciato
però mi sono chiesto come mai come mai
queste frasi che erano incredibilmente
con volute arrotolate
sono state scelte invece di usare un
linguaggio assolutamente capace di
trasmettere gli stessi messaggi ma più
facile e ho pensato che probabilmente
c'entra qualcosa con narcisismo e ci
arrivò nel senso che noi fin dalle medie
forse prima non lo so però ci insegnano
che il linguaggio deve essere ricco il
vocabolario deve essere ampio e ci sta
c'è un momento in cui usarlo il più
banale dei temi se scritto in modo molto
complicato alle medie l'abbiamo fatto
tutti prende un voto migliore è
premiante quella roba lì ok e quindi
cresciamo facendo un'associazione
pericolosissima ma è incredibilmente
diffusa cioè
se devo essere autorevole se devo
suonare autorevole devo parlare
difficile e quello c'entra più che altro
con la figura che abbiamo paura di fare
o non fare noi davanti alle persone ma
si dimentica di un dettaglio
importantissimo che la comunicazione si
fa in due o in tanti però
tendenzialmente se io lancio un
messaggio e quel messaggio non supera la
prova della decodifica da parte del
ricevente questo era un pallone per ora
per dire se parlo e qualcuno anzi
nessuno capisce
non è efficace comunicazione
ok è un fallimento
ma c'è dell'altro ancora cioè che quando
ci insegnano a usare
determinato linguaggio cioè a usare un
linguaggio aulico alto forbito ricco
eccetera non ci insegnano quando usarlo
perché lo ripeto è assolutamente
fondamentale saper parlare molto bene a
seconda dell'occasione
ma a seconda dell'occasione
per esempio io a un certo punto della
mia vita mi sono trovato a fare il prof
il prof di italiano con i ragazzi del
liceo in realtà un professionale ok e mi
sono trovato a spiegare
determinati temi argomenti dell'italiano
a un pubblico particolarmente restio nel
senso che loro erano in quella scuola
per imparare a fare i baristi a fare i
panettieri a fare i cuochi che va
benissimo ok non gliene importava nulla
delle materie scolastiche
e mi sono trovato davanti a questo
problema qua ciò è spiegare cose che
potevano essere complicate cercando di
rendere il più facile possibile
interessanti ok che è quello che siamo
abituati a fare in realtà
quotidianamente solo che non ci facciamo
caso perché noi umani
tutti siamo delle macchine di
comunicazione cioè riusciamo a capire
molto bene e in pochissimo tempo che
abbiamo davanti provate a pensare nella
vita di tutti i giorni no andate a fare
la spesa e parlate con un commesso
parlate con il vostro partner quando
arrivate a casa
parlate con la vostra datrice di lavoro
usate sempre dei registri diversi
ovviamente a meno che non state
inquietantemente affettuosi con i
commessi però
questo vuol dire che noi siamo capaci di
farlo semplicemente non lo facciamo per
una scelta più o meno consapevole ci
dimentichiamo
di metterci bing sulla stessa frequenza
di chi ci sta parlando o meglio di chi
ci sta ascoltando e viceversa in realtà
facciamo fatica
a metterci sullo stesso piano ogni tanto
dicevo quando mi sono trovato a fare il
prof e dovevo spiegare cosi difficili
uno dei primi grandi ostacoli è stato
non mi ricordo perché eravamo in quella
parte del programma spiegare il concetto
di
analessi e prolessi
che poi è flashback flashforward o
banalmente quando la narrazione va
indietro
come va avanti
spiegarlo applicato a un testo classico
selan alessi e la prolessi applicato su
un testo già complicato dopo di per sé
che il mio allievo non leggerà mai nella
vita e che non gliene frega niente e chi
sono io per giudicarlo d'altra parte per
questa sua scelta va benissimo così non
ha senso
è molto più facile per esempio ma è un
esempio non è una genialata
semplicemente chiedergli per esempio di
raccontarmi il suo sabato sera cosa hai
fatto sabato sera e poi fargli notare
che mentre mi raccontava il sabato sera
e mi ha raccontato dove ha conosciuto ad
esempio anni prima gli amici con cui è
uscito ha fatto delle analisi ha fatto
dei flashback e che quando mi ha detto
come cercherà di conquistare la sua
amata sabato prossimo non ha detto
proprio amata però era quello che non ho
il significato ha usato una prolessi ok
è che il bebè che flashforward sono
assolutamente presenti un sacco di
racconti un sacco di letteratura
naturalmente ma anche nel cinema anche
in un fast and furious è pieno ok è
quella roba lì se la ricorda
quindi il discorso quale è che se noi
perdessimo la paura di fare una
figuraccia senza usare le parole one
cioè se tutti quelli che si trovano a
dover insegnare delle cose in realtà
perdessero il timore di non suonare
autorevoli per il fatto di non usare
certo tipo di linguaggio secondo me ne
guadagneremmo tutti perché per ora
l'umanità è un po come se destinasse
parte della propria cultura a tenerla in
un caveau
coperta da un muro di
complicazioni artificiali in realtà ok
non è molto democratico non è alla
portata di tutti e questo un peccato
secondo me in generale poi c'è anche il
fatto che naturalmente un paziente che
va dal medico ha una gran voglia gran
bisogno di capire perfettamente quello
che sta sentendo magari anche
preoccupato giustamente e oggi in italia
il percorso di medicina non prevede una
branca destinata alla comunicazione per
i medici cioè se un medico ha un buon
tutor del suo corso che vi spiega quella
che è la sua esperienza personale sul
come si dicono certe cose
bene se non sta alla sua buona volontà
ed è un peccato anche questo
ma anche per i normali cittadini cioè
tutti noi che a un certo punto dobbiamo
fare un incidente con le istituzioni ci
perdiamo affoghiamo in un mare di
burocratese senza capire una mazza
quando le cose sono potenzialmente molto
facili si possono rendere davvero in due
righe per cui tutta questa roba
che ci ho messo più meno dieci minuti a
dirvi in realtà riassumendo molto di più
si potrebbe dire secondo me è molto
meglio parlare facile grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]